i think it is harmful for the trans
athletes to be told
like if they identify as male that they
are not yeah um and so i said you just
you just said male 1 uh-huh
that's sex sex that's not gender oh
sorry whatever is the gender no you
can't keep it straight can you i mean
it's it's cause it's silly it's a little
silly
it's time for another installment of
change my mind the series where we
rationalize our positions on
controversial topics now today's subject
is a hot one in the news lately
biological males
in women's sports
a victoria woman who won a world
championship in master cycling has been
hit with a wave of backlash because she
is transgender new zealand has chosen
the first transgender athlete to compete
at its olympic games it's also reignited
a debate with critics who say it's
unfair transgender swimmer leah thomas
breaking barriers and records sports
illustrated calls the college senior the
most controversial athlete in america
the beauty of changed my mind is that
almost invariably productive dialogue
takes place and people generally leave
feeling better than they can which is
exactly what happened here but
not everyone from the tolerant activist
left was so happy about
you know conversation
[Applause]
what's the message of radical trans
liberation now what does it mean i'm not
here to talk to you stephen no no one
radical transliberation now
look
i'm slightly chocolatey
this one's still a mystery to me we're
still trying to identify
the gender is it male
female z male trigender either way i was
greatly inconvenienced if you figure it
out comment below the point is some
people just don't know how to use their
words unlike this person
isaac with whom i had a conversation
that
was a little more productive isaac
steven nice to meet you nice to meet you
so uh isaac i don't know i know you said
you've watched the show uh yes okay so i
don't know how familiar you are kind of
with this but the idea is that we you
know sit down with
people hopefully where it's a a rational
discussion uh on uh
what are sort of controversial topics
and often people have rational
discussions doing topics that are oh
okay it's easy to have a rational
discussion it's easy to rationalize your
position the second it gets into
something that may be emotionally
charged we throw it out the window so
that's what it is in the bottom line
today's topic uh i do not believe that
biological males should be allowed to
compete in women's sports
uh obviously you disagree to some degree
yes um
feel free to you know make your case and
change my mind okay um
i guess my first point of contention
would be with the wording of the
statement um biological males should not
compete i'm curious as to why it would
be biological males and not trans women
yeah should not compete because i feel
like there is a distinction there even
if it is you know maybe an arbitrary one
in your case well how is it not
arbitrary um how is it not oh you mean
the distinction between trans yeah so
when you say that for example i could
use either term interchangeably yeah uh
biological males was something that
everyone would understand so why is it
so important to you
uh that that terminology be changed
yeah i feel like um a lot of the times
people use like biology as a sort of
like
constant you know obviously i'm sure you
believe maybe i'm wrong that like
biology it's a binary and that there's
male and female
and that it's it's just like that is
that correct
and that you can be one or the other and
that it's there's no as a general
they're obviously radical exceptions
people like intersex people or people
with you know androgen resistance or
stuff but we're talking about you know
point zero one percent of the population
so yes obviously uh and obviously even
people who believe in the uh transgender
ideology yeah have
long agreed that biology exists in a
binary oh for sure not gender but
biology yeah no definitely um so we
agree that biological sex
is or at least
would you
uh agree
with my presumption here that certainly
what's being taught on school is that
gender and sex are different and the
primary difference is sex is biological
and gender is societal oh yeah i would
agree with that okay all right so okay
so sorry continue with your point as to
why you would prefer it be worded
with trans women versus biological um
because i do believe that as far as um
expression goes like obviously there is
that difference that you're talking
about um and even in trans women a lot
of them who do compete um
in sports um there is obviously the
hormonal like you know estrogen and like
like all the like treatment that they go
through which
does alter their physical sort of like
ability to compete in these sports um
and so to to save biological men instead
of trans women um
sort of
indicates that there is no difference
when i think there probably is
i would argue
maybe i'm misunderstanding your point
because you just said that gender is
societal yeah
sex is biological yeah so the reason
that i am saying is biological males
yeah is because this is biological right
males yeah but then you're saying you
would rather see trans women which is
societal it's not biological
sports are separated by biology that's
why there are male female divisions yes
and up until recently male female
divisions men's and women's divisions
they were always separated by biology
and you're suggesting that it would be
more conducive to an accurate assessment
here by using a gendered term rather
than biological okay i see your point
now yes um so i would could see to you
on that as far as like the distinction
i'm fine with the wording if that is
sort of your you know um
well i won't understand your position
because you just said that gender and
sex are different yes and my issue is
with i don't care someone wants to
identify yeah right if they want to
identify uh as a woman yeah in society
yeah that's a totally separate issue
we're talking about sports which which
have been separated by biological sex
okay
we were talking about biological males
who are now
dominating biological females okay so
my point of contention with what you
just said there would be that biological
males are dominating biological females
i have not seen that play out um
obviously there's a few cases here and
there but i could easily just make the
argument that leah thomas came in eighth
in one of her races and came in fifth in
another one
um and so i would set the record in one
yes and set the record with a time that
would have ranked not even the top 500
yeah right not even the top 500 male
rankings yeah uh for the 500 meter not
even the top 800 for the 200 meter which
i believe is what leah thomas won
you're saying the record he said when he
was
a race with women yeah would not even
right
500. and how does that further your
point
well the point is there that says
someone who was competing as a male yeah
was a middling to low end of the pack
yes male 1 yes and is now a champion
female my
argument to that would just be that the
reason why he was middle of the pack was
because he was on hormones
he had begun to transition while he was
competing against men as far as i was
aware no and certainly and if you would
argue that it would certainly only be
the tail end not for the entirety of his
athletic career oh no no not from the
entirety right but when you're looking
at those middle of the pack numbers i
believe and
obviously it's just your word against my
word so
i'm not gonna like stay on this point no
and i appreciate it yeah and i try and
make all the references publicly
available so when this goes up yeah yeah
because i can just easily get something
wrong for example i could be mixing up
the 200 and 500 meter right and i know
that he won
one of them and it's kind of then he
you're missing the forest for the trees
yeah exactly because there are many many
examples of biological males dominating
um biological females you know there are
over 80 examples of women who either
lost out on opportunities or
scholarships you have mary gregory i
believe in powerlifting you have women
cycling a record that was set you have
examples across the board in
weightlifting in cycling in swimming in
track yeah um not to mention combat
sports where women can actually be
physically harmed so yeah it has
happened quite a bit now granted it's
such a small percentage of the
population
um what i want to avoid is
and and i mean this genuinely i'm not
just blown smoke you seem like a sharp
guy
you know
that intellectual fallacy of appeal to
novelty right that argumentum novotatum
is what they'll call it but appeal to
novelty which means well since we
haven't done it yet
therefore there are no consequences well
it's just because we haven't done it yet
this is very very new and where we have
implemented these uh types of policies
we've seen an unbelievable differential
between the biological males and women
it's just we've only been doing this for
a few years it's like saying well there
are no negative consequences to a 90
income tax
yet sure but if we implement it tomorrow
and it takes five years to see all the
bankruptcies right it's not really an
argument so where we have implemented it
we have seen quite a few examples okay
um but it is on a smaller scale because
it would have been considered absurd
five years ago and it's hard for me to
contextualize that 80 number that you
gave because i do not know what the
total is so it's like not it's a it's a
hard number rather than a percentage so
it's hard for me to take that at face
value
let's say it's not let's say it's not
that much okay it's still more than one
sure right yeah and then we can get to
my issues no
for example you mentioned hormones
so i want to make sure that i understand
this because i think you're actually
arguing
what a lot of people argue and i can
understand why people would would think
this way yeah that if a
a biological male undergoes hormone
replacement that they're not they no
longer would have the biological
advantages and you know inferred i'm not
necessarily saying that obviously that
that
is the majority but it's obviously not
in every case so if someone did not
undergo hormone replacement therapy at
all
you would be against them competing
against um i actually don't know um it's
it's a very well bring it up situation
oh just because like as far as like
because you brought that up that was one
of the first things yes just just in the
case of like oh like these people are
just dominating and whatever and in the
case of like um
um leah thomas competing against men it
was more so just to say that like he was
competing against men while he was on
hormones um but the
my my greater sort of because you do
bring up a good point which is that it
is more than one
like who is going to be harmed um and i
don't think in my mind there's a perfect
answer to this sort of because in my
mind there's a couple different options
it's either you okay like what
exclude transgender people entirely from
competing and that's not what it's for
that's not what i'm suggesting yeah
totally i don't think they just compete
with their biological sex right yeah so
and then there is the other option of
letting them compete with their
biological sex um
i believe you do run into the same
problems um which is that if you are to
let
um biological women compete with
transgender men who are once women
you're essentially pinning women against
in your mind other women who are just
basically doping legally because they're
on hormones or they're taking some sort
of testosterone or something like that
so you run into the same problem when
they're competing as like who they were
assigned
what their gender was biologically at
birth you see what i'm saying are you
saying a biological woman yeah competing
against a trans man who was previously a
woman
let's just stick with the term biology
here because using gender terms so a
biological woman yes competing against a
biological uh woman yes who is on like
you know steroids yeah yeah like or you
know like um or testosterone yeah which
would improve their performance right
yeah so
it runs into the same problem
which is exactly what we're allowing
with the trans athletes so the reason i
bring that up is because i don't know if
you know this but the international
olympic committee doesn't require any
hormone replacement therapy at all okay
none
uh and what happened with leah thomas
and this was shocking to me was now a
big reason that the ioc does that is
they say well we pumped it to the
organizations of the individual sports
and you and i both know of course being
on campus i think you're probably to the
left of center but i don't think you're
someone who believes in stifling speech
or ideas you know we're shutting people
down that would be a bad thing yes
exactly uh but we both know that smaller
sports organizations are more prone
you know to succumbing to the pressure
of activist groups right so the ioc says
we'll punt it to these organizations
with the ncaa what happened and i'm just
using this because it's the most recent
example yeah what happened is the ncaa
had rules they said no we're going to go
up to uh the national swimming
organizing body i believe it's usa
swimming i may have that wrong i think
it's usa
sure i said 36 months
of hormone replacement therapy okay the
ncaa said we're not going to do that
you just have to tell us you're doing 12
months of hormone replacement therapy
and you just need to submit one test
within four weeks of competition and
you're only allowed to have the
testosterone levels twice that of a
normal female i believe it's five either
nanomoles per deciliter or five
nanograms per deciliter uh
ceiling it's a seal you can't go past
that you can't do it but but for a trans
athlete you can't go past ten okay which
is two times that of a woman so it'd be
like you going into a sport have you
ever played sports i have yes okay so
what sport what's your sport basketball
oh basketball okay so um
yeah you can't find a juicer in
professional basketball right no no of
course not they're all naturals
but
it would be like telling
lebron james what would be like telling
i don't follow college basketball but
whoever's good in college basketball be
like saying okay look look you're not
allowed to do steroids you say you're
not doing them for 12 months and then
within four weeks you just submit a
blood test where you only have two times
the testosterone levels of your male
counterparts okay you know we always
talk about steroids in sports right and
how
how it's become easier to beat these
sort of tests and the tests become more
elaborate
this is a cheat sheet to transgender
males to biological males claiming to be
women yeah on how to cheat it's we're
only going to need a test within four
weeks and you're still allowed to have
two times the levels okay and uh even
then you know what's also important is
and i understand what you're saying i
guess i don't know what your position is
my position is biological males compete
with biological males biological females
compete with biological females that was
a position
of even modern transgender activists
until just really two three years ago
because all sports are different that's
biology yeah um
now we're at a point where we're
trying to make the argument that well if
they undergo hormone replacement therapy
for a year they don't have and that's
also not true the medical literature
this this isn't up to date with the data
they only lose about five percent of
their strengths we're talking not just
strengths i mean you're talking about
legal state it's about five percent
according to the medical literature they
live in five percent in 12 months
um okay i've seen it as high as seven
okay
the most legitimate study that i've seen
the most legitimate studies
you're measuring like physical strength
or endurance physical strength capacity
muscle area total muscle volume muscle
density see volume connective tissue
strength for example male connective
tissue strength ligament strength tendon
strength is 80 higher red blood cell
count vo2 max overall lung capacity uh
lever arms longer i mean bone density
list goes on and on these don't go away
with 12 months they don't even go with
two years yeah i mean i would argue
things like wing span bone density all
that stuff is the same um but like
certain you know
bone density is the same between a male
and a female oh no i was saying after
you are on hormones for a while your
your wingspan things like that that sort
are like your height is not necessarily
going to change although that does
happen sometimes i think but i don't
think that's always all the you're being
on estrogen you're saying yeah your
wingspan wouldn't change exactly you
would still enjoy the
length and wingspan of being a
biological man but
i do think there are certain physical
attributes that do change like as far as
like you know like strength is a big one
like there'd be like how many push-ups
you can do there's studies where they'll
test pre and post training it gets lower
yeah yeah it even evens out pretty much
not in the studies that i've seen no i
guess so yeah and this is another one
where you can just go back and forth
your word my word i don't really want to
camp out on that you know i think we can
just sort of agree to disagree i think
the data is is pretty clear and i think
look let's let's say let's say that
you're correct yeah
let's say that there are studies out
there that show after a year of
testosterone suppression everything is
the same let's assume that's correct i
don't believe so let's assume it's
correct
um
still doesn't bring us to a solution
does that um
not a very clean one no so what are you
suggesting what do i'm saying that
biological males compete with biological
males
because i believe someone also needs to
advocate for biological females that's
why title ix exists yeah
um
your suggestion is my suggestion is to
let like trans athletes play with so
like i'd say let trans men compete in
men's sports and like trans women
compete in women's sports um
when you say trans men again you're
using a gender so you're arguing that
gender and sex are the same uh no not
necessarily well because you're saying
let trans men compete in men's sports
let trans women what you're really
saying is biological males who identify
as women competing women sports and
sports are separated by biology there's
no getting around that so if you were
saying yeah but it's not like a constant
like a wild nature or something like
that that can change
it has been a constant but for a very
good reason the reason it's the same
reason we have weight classes that's the
same reason we have age divisions it's
not like gravity that you can't you know
what i mean like it is a it's a
construct that we can morph if we
find the social utility for it you see
what i'm saying and what would the
social utility be so
to up ending um based on sparse or
non-existent clinical data that you're
mentioning
what would the what would the upside be
to allowing biological males to be yeah
because you know it's not going the
other direction you and i both know that
right there's the lab study and then
there's a real life study biological
women are not
competing and beating men
biological no i mean listen
listen
biological differences between when men
and women on general do exist right
and so i'm not definitely not going to
argue with that but when you bring trans
people into the equation
i'm looking at it from the perspective
of what is going to
like it's like a harm reduction type of
like a perspective of coming from so it
goes back to my earlier point which is
even if you wanted to say okay
biological men and biological women
compete in like separate sports and then
like it doesn't matter if you transition
over or not you have to compete with who
you were biologically assigned with at
birth it still just creates the same
problem where women who want to
transition to men have to compete
against women and then it's not fair to
the women who are getting you know beat
up on by this
transition like this trans man yeah who
is taking hormones and is taking well
they shouldn't be allowed to compete
okay so you're saying
is that your women yes a woman who is
taking
anabolics yeah effectively transitioning
to a woman who's taking out about a
woman who's taking antibiotics let's
boil this down to biological terms
someone's taking testosterone sure
no non-trans-identifying woman is
allowed to do that they're banned from
sport okay it's illegal okay should be
illegal regardless how you identify okay
they shouldn't be allowed to beat up on
women
just like a woman shouldn't be allowed
to
take anabolic steroids
okay and that is a fine position hold
it's not my position that's a harm
reduction position so that's my harm
reduction position
what's the harm reduction you're saying
your harm reduction model
in allowing biological men to beat women
i would like as many people to
participate in sports as possible while
still keeping because like you said
trans like the trans community is a
fairly small one this is not
a sort of an epidemic or a pandemic like
some maybe make it out to be it's a it's
a small it's not yet no it's not yeah
it's not sure it's not yet because it's
very important
and if it does change and it becomes a
really big problem then maybe we can
readdress how we sort of go about this
so let let a problem that all data would
indicate is likely going to happen and
even the small sample sizes that we have
allow that problem to run its course
allow it to rob women of opportunities
allow it to create concussions and
broken orbital bones like we've seen in
women's combat sports because we don't
know how bad it'll be yet
and then reverse course if it gets worse
my argument would be that it is not a
problem yet once it does become a
problem then we can address it but as of
right now in the current moment i don't
see it as being uh probable
so i think in your harm reduction you
are failing to take into account
one large group of people okay
you're taking into account a very small
group of people
and you've
i don't think you've mean but you've
conflated gender and sex which is why
modern gender theory is one i disagree
with because it's not a tenable position
sure
uh because everything that you have
discussed is basically equating gender
with sex at that point that's the only
way you can argue that people who
identify a certain way should be able to
compete with people who are biologically
female but let's say it's one percent of
the population that's trans
okay
in your harm reduction approach
who are you ignoring
uh well i'm assuming from your
perspective biological way right yeah
but you would have to sort of explain to
me why that is the case if it is one
percent of people who are trans well you
know what's the purpose to sports
uh
why do we play store competition i mean
that's a great question i don't know i
don't have philosophies for you what's
been doing in the sport to win i'm
assuming yes okay that's the only goal
you know have fun along the way maybe i
don't know yeah sure you have fun along
the way camaraderie but when we're
talking about sports and high level
sports like ncaa it's not fun i mean
they're not trying to be achieving at
that point right it's a very difficult
life they've sacrificed a lot yeah
they've trained a lot they've run into
many uh complications that people who
are not trying to be excellent i think
we would both agree with that right it's
not really a fun life to be an ncaa
silver medalist
should be an olympic silver medalist and
then get your ass kicked by someone who
was a man two years ago yeah
um
so the purpose is to win
now
that's why sports exist
the ncaa right collegiate sports
what opportunities do those provide
we both agree that they're significant
oh yeah for sure scholarships
paths to careers coaching yeah okay
so beyond the actual physical harm which
can take place
in certain sports
uh with biological men competing against
women
what about all the economic harm what
about all the opportunity costs for
these women who've trained their whole
lives and they miss out
well so
because far more of them will be
affected than
transgender individuals who um
don't even compete in sport
what do you mean by that what i mean is
if we have one percent of transgender
individuals right in the population not
many of them are competing in sports
it's a lot of harm reduction strategy
that um at the cost of
all of the other women in these sports
who are vying for these opportunities
we are acquiescing to biological males
in the name of harm reduction but it's
actually probably the most harmful we
can harmful thing we can do
for women's sports for female sports
um i guess my argument for that would
just be that you know you're talking
about
you're framing in a sense that like
trans women are taking opportunities
from biological women i assume is the
the point here yeah i would just say
that it's it's not sort of a
if you want to make because i do think
there is going to be harm done either
way i will agree but i think it's sort
of it's more of a one-to-one thing
you're making it seem like biological
women are going to be hurt
um exponentially more when it's it's
like if a trans woman takes a biological
woman's place that's a one-to-one sort
of trade-off i mean one or the other is
going to take that place of the other
person so
it's it's just depending on who you want
to favor as and it just comes back down
to i believe like what you view it like
the women's sports thing is sort of a
microcosm of the bigger sort of trends
like i be you know like
it it pivots on well it shows that it
shows that modern gender theory can't
hold water oh why is that well because
i've been even at this school in other
schools there are only two genders right
change my mind and people well no no
gender is separate from sex yeah
okay let's go with that yeah but now
you're sitting here arguing gender and
sex are interchangeable
um i wouldn't argue they're
interchangeable well you are even in the
realm of sport um not necessarily
no okay then please clarify because i
just heard you say that
biological males
and then you use the term trans women
which is a danger term right trans women
is not a biological term that's a gender
term yes so you say people of a gender
should be allowed to now
identify with whatever sex they choose
to see what you're saying now so i would
like to clarify that then okay um
people who identify as men
should be allowed to compete against
each other people who identify as women
should be allowed to compete against
each other i i make no
biological so separate distinctions
there so separate division
no non-separate division i just think
that it brings us back to the same issue
you're saying biological males who
identify as trans women a gender term
yeah
brings us right back to the same place
should be able to compete against other
people who are separated by sex
there's only an exception
for the modern transgender theorists
right everywhere else that's separated
by biology no i can't compete against
women just because
i don't say that i'm a woman yeah i
could tomorrow yeah
um well so
just to that point i don't think that is
something that is really happening or
people just being like i'm a man i'm
just gonna say i'm a woman and go
compete against women and like i don't
think that is a thing that happens i do
believe it is legitimate like tr
people who are legitimately trying to
transition who want to compete in these
sports well how do you know um because i
mean look at leah thomas look at all the
examples that you yourself have cited i
have not seen an example of
like a person doing that yet and if that
does happen again then it becomes a
problem and we forget about it it has
happened and again just because it
hasn't happened yet that's the you know
argument nova todd and that's the art
that's true appeal to novelty logical
foul
this isn't even because i don't want to
go back to the thing you were saying
about the the men and women the
biological yes
i don't understand how your position i
don't understand how your position is
tenable if gender and sex are separate
so my only point that i i would like to
make is when you say men's and women's
sports yes
i would like that to just simply mean
people who identify as men people who
identify as one but it doesn't um not
right now no but it could and it doesn't
because of biological differences sports
are separated due to biological
differences right now yes um and there's
a reason for that well i mean for the
safety of women um well and then it just
goes back to the same argument we kind
of are going no it's not going back to
the same argument you haven't addressed
it for the safety of women well we went
back and forth on the data of does it
actually harm women in the sense of like
because i mean obviously you mentioned
like broken orbital bones and all that
stuff in combat sports which
injuries are going to happen in the
realm of obviously an orbital bone is a
pretty serious i mean that's a that's a
bad one but
injuries are going to happen in the
realm of combat sports deciding that let
me ask you this because
do you not believe that there would be
more injuries occurring in contact
sports
if biological men just compete if there
are no men and women's divisions do you
honestly not believe that that would
drastically increase the chances of
injury well you know i think come on we
have people who are walking cte right
the the lifespan of an o-lineman is
somewhere in their 40s or 50s in the nfl
these are 315 340 pound men and they're
still having to deal with being hit do
you honestly believe that if we didn't
have men and women's division that a
woman
a female quarterback being sacked
or a female linemen you don't you really
don't think that there would be an
increase in dramatic interest no there
would yeah definitely but i would like
to note that
like obviously
it hasn't happened yet well of course
there is you know differences
in men and women like a you know big
linebacker versus small but i would like
to point out that whenever you do talk
about sort of
biological differences why do you do
this uh sorry yeah i don't know yeah but
whenever you talk about what do you mean
to do this or was that accidental let's
not read too deeply into it i don't
think it's really anything
is it because i am saying i'm being i
think it matters biological males well
but you did this yeah so let me get to
the point is that when you do talk about
biological distinctions what you're
really saying are
physical chemical distinctions between
people right like i could say that oh a
six six
through 230 pound like linebacker versus
like
you know like a college like a freshman
of the same age who's like five five and
like 180 pounds or whatever
is not going to be a fair matchup right
but they're both men but when you say
biological differences you're talking
about
physical
you know
competitive advantages that people have
regardless of biology yeah i mean sorry
regardless of what their what they are
assigned at birth as far as regardless
biology determines them to be at birth
um but you know it determines them to an
extent but do you believe that
biological male and biological female is
assigned at birth or do you believe that
the gender assigned at birth is what can
be changed because this is very new you
need to understand this oh yeah yeah the
students i spoke with two years ago yeah
at this school
the professors
never in their wildest dreams would have
said
biological sex assigned at first yeah
are you suggesting that sex is being
assigned rather than being intrinsic
because that's a whole new thing the the
chromosomes that you are born with are
the ones that you have and it's not a
socially constructed thing okay you have
those chromosomes it determines a lot
about your physical makeup and stuff
like that but you know
and obviously there's
intersex people and it's a spectrum and
all that and it's not a binary but it is
intrinsic it is biological you can't you
know just say that you don't have these
certain chromosomes and but i don't
think that's the argument people are
making so that would be my you know
well you don't think one is the argument
every single person in this country
thinks that it's unfair for biological
males
to compete against biological females
not the realm of competition i'm just
simply saying i don't think anybody is
making the argument that
you
are not born with chromosomes that give
you certain you know like that that's
different do you understand that then
your position is untenable
because you're saying there is something
that is innate there is something that
is intrinsic right there is something
that's immutable yeah uh but we need to
throw that out the window as it relates
to sports and go by gender which is
societal um
i see your point but the problem is that
sports are not separated by how you
identify they are separated by
immutable immutable physical
characteristics
for the reason of safety and fairness
and competition so can we agree on that
that's why they're separated by biology
i might agree but if you're going off of
specifically so your definition of why
they are separated is a musical physical
characteristics yes for people's safety
i would just make the argument and
fairness right i would just make the
argument okay so we should have smaller
men and women compete against each other
and women who are at a better physical
because you you would you would
acknowledge that division one versus
division three and we have weight
classes perfect sure yeah exactly
you would not cross the biological lines
to
like the gender you know the sex no
because the difference is so vast i mean
not for everybody though right
i mean because if you want to make the
argument that it is for the safety of
people it absolutely is unbelievably the
gap is so much larger between men and
women it's not even close i mean you can
look at the again when you're looking at
just leah thomas as a recent example
talking about 503 i believe in the 200
or 500 something place yeah if that time
were posted
by when he was still competing as a man
not even top 800 in the 500
right it's a huge and you're talking
about winning yeah one of them placing
fifth in another it's not even close
yeah i'm even just do you think serena
williams and venus williams you think
they would do well against top guys oh
no i should actually clarify do you
think they would even do well against
middling guys um i'm not sure about
millionaires but do you think they would
do well against not good tennis at a
high level there is a complete
difference between men and women as far
as like physical advantage my point is
the best female athletes in the world
aren't even close to middling to low-end
male athletes that's a
can you substantiate that claim yeah
venus and serena williams they fought
they uh played tennis against a guy who
was ranked 204th i believe and he beat
both of them in one afternoon that's
kind of it and he was a drunk
i think that's an anecdotal maybe a
point to make right now you just ask me
can i can i point to an example yeah and
then
the empirical would be okay so the
empirical would be the times that i just
gave you for leah thomas right i can
give you other examples like mary
gregory and power lifting the squat
swirl record female squat versus male
squat is a 400 pound difference when
you're talking about men in the same
weight class who are competing against
each other you're talking about
infinitesimal
right amounts of weight you're talking
about two three pounds you're talking
about the world record deadlift going up
if you're lucky by four pounds maybe
every two years right that's the level
of competition the difference between a
man and a woman is over 400 pounds i
just gave you the times right the
empirical as far as the swim times you
could actually look at every single swim
time track time right
decathlon time you could look at every
single shot put you could look at every
single long jump high jump you could
look at the verticals you can look at
connective tissue strength like i said
which is about 80 higher immense you can
look at all those that's the empirical
sure and i'm giving you an example of
the two best female tennis players who
have ever existed were both just
absolutely washed in an afternoon by a
drunken 200 something ranked guy yeah so
it's a big difference well yeah i mean i
would say that's not the college thing
this is a big big difference yeah yeah
in a high level competition
women against low level men it's not
even close well and you know
to be honest i don't know if that super
matters female athletes in the world get
routed by adolescent boys do you know
that the world women's
right the world female soccer champions
they lose
almost always to high school boy teams
um so i don't know if that's super i
feel like we're kind of getting off on a
separate path here as far as like well
no i'm just addressing your argument
recently well the difference is
depending i said no no it's such a huge
chasm yeah between biological males and
females that that's the reason they're
separated i was addressing your point i
would still make the argument that the
chasm is not as big as you make it out
to be okay um but
my word against your word i don't want
to look anything i would argue that it
is not as big as because obviously sure
i asked for
evidence and there is a lot of i'm sure
specific examples assuming that i'm not
lying oh i don't think you're lying i
think all of those examples that you
gave are very well this could be true
but again empirical and the anecdotal
right you recognize that i gave you the
empirical what can be measured in a lab
what can be measured as far as times
across the board yeah and then the
anecdotal of the best female athletes
competing against middling drunken men
and still losing yeah and females are
fairly more confident that those the lab
the numbers that you give are not
totally accurate yeah um okay and then
as far as like the individual cases yeah
they are individual cases so i'm not
gonna you know
discount the empirical and discount the
anecdotal
now it's the broad and now it's the
brutal and nothing is safe
yeah that's good that was a good framing
you just did but i would say that i
would discount the anecdotal yes i will
acknowledge that but the empirical i do
believe like i have seen a lot of
evidence that points towards my
um point of view what if you're wrong
if i'm wrong then i would be okay with
it because i feel like i would have at
least tried to protect the rights of all
people to play sports
you well i mean you were the one who
said that you would not let trans men
compete in sports
you mean women you mean biological
females who are taking drugs yes for the
same yeah you just can't take anabolic
steroids in the sport yeah now if you're
advocating that we should allow anabolic
steroids in sport fine how about it no
i'm allowed i know i'm i'm advocating
that
like which by the way i'm not even
necessarily against yeah oh you're not
i'm not even necessarily against it no i
think either we need to have really
really strict testing across the board
or no testing and let the game begin
okay so this is that reasonable um it's
got to be one or the other we have
shitty testing right now that people can
bypass yeah yeah for sure yeah well
honestly i don't have a super like heart
and fast opinion on that specifically
our very strongest community
a lot of fun to see a bunch of royal
athletes go up against each other but
especially sports like baseball oh yeah
i mean i don't watch baseball you just
want to hit him
at home runs they're not hitting anybody
i would watch baseball if that was the
case yeah i think you wouldn't be over
on that okay all right that's fine
baseball would be less boring if we just
let them
let them ride yeah exactly you know it's
like the tour de france do you see that
at the tour de france you know they they
just excoriated you know lance armstrong
and i don't remember the number because
you know now they can retroactively go
and test the samples really with modern
testing methods
and they tested all of the other guys
who we beat you know who sued him and
were complaining and they had to go down
to like number i think it was 14 to find
someone who was clean and now none of
the records none of the records are
being set they were all set a few years
ago so no it makes a big difference yeah
and by the way you know what's
interesting about that
the difference of a man on steroids
picture the most jacked out dude you
know on the bodybuilding stage does not
enjoy anywhere near the exponential
hormonal advantage
that a male enjoys over a female arnold
in his prime
does not have a hormonal advantage over
you
that you do over her or her or her
it's very big of a chasm i could i could
probably concede to that i think that's
probably maybe true um i i don't think
it sways my because i guess my question
to you
would just be
um
what what do how do you address like the
leah thomases and all the like
transgender athletes who want to compete
it's your opinion is strictly
just so i'm i'm clear biological i'll
give you i'll give you two okay okay so
one is and they're not going to like it
you're going to think i'm a dick
you were competing as a man two years
ago you continue to compete as a man
okay okay
that's the only fair way to do it or
if i go along with the idea which you
have presented and your peers here have
presented and your professors have
presented that gender and sex
are different
then you have to change it based on
gender and create a third division let
me ask you this actually might help how
many genders are there
um
how many genders are there
[Music]
more than two
i don't know
more than three
why does it matter i guess is my
question like then you have to just
create as many divisions as there are
genders
um so one of those two
you compete based on biology like we
always have because it's what's safe
it's what's fair it's what protects
women or if you want to go with sort of
modern gender theory which i don't agree
with but i would allow forward in sport
where okay uh i think facebook has you
up to 50 something dinners now maybe
higher than that
great 50 something sports divisions
compete in those against your gender it
it feels a bit like like hyperbole to me
because i don't feel like there is a cry
for that to for there to be 50 like
obviously of course they want to beat up
on women
yeah but i'm saying i'm addressing your
point that you're making currently which
is that i don't think that is an issue
or a problem or anybody's okay to start
to happen
um create a third one where all the
people can take all the hormones they
want is this your solution for the
problem it's one of two my solution is
you go with biology because sports have
been separated by biology if we need to
protect trans athletes i don't really
know what that necessarily means i don't
know how they're going to be harmed by
not being allowed to dominate women at a
swim meet create a third division i mean
i would argue trans people do get like
they're the target of hate crimes fairly
frequently more so than your average
person it's not a hate crime to not let
them compete oh no i'm not talking about
not like i'm talking about hate crimes
in general
if you want to talk about the protection
of trans
a people putting women biological
females at risk i don't see that as a
form of protection well so i think what
it all kind of comes down to and this is
why i think that at the end of the day
women's sports like are sort of a and
this is not me sort of can see because i
still do but at the end of the day
it's very important i think that you
affirm
somebody's gender identity as they
identify with it so i think it is
harmful for the trans athletes to be
told
like if they identify as male that they
are not yeah um and so i said you just
you just said male 1
that's sex sex that's not gender oh
sorry whatever is the gender no you
can't keep it straight can you i mean
it's it's i won't because it's silly
it's a little silly
when i get down to a point for you to
say hey you said trans men before use
pawn this is and i want to i want to
wrap this up with here because this
isn't a gotcha this is me trying i don't
fully understand your argument and then
as long as i can respond after you can
well because we do have to get going so
i think you just presented your your
kind of closing sentiment here but it
matters because the very first thing you
did when you sat down
do you remember what it was that you
said when i said bio you said you had a
problem with the wording
and the problem that you had with the
wording was that i kept saying
biological males yeah right yeah and you
said
we should use the term trans women
right yeah but right now you just
reverted back to saying they identify as
females males so you yourself the
biggest problem that you had when you
sat down here that wasn't the biggest
problem it's the first thing i said but
it wasn't the best we said that your
primary issue was with the wording i
don't think it was primary i don't think
that's what i said okay it's the first
issue
but right now you just committed the
same sin i don't think so i mean maybe i
got my words mixed up but i'm not going
to sit here and claim that like you
didn't get your words mixed up you're
being very articulate and i and i think
you've been articulate this whole time i
think we disagree well thank you yeah
but i really do think that you've been
articulate and i think you've been um i
mean you're probably kind of i don't
know you're probably not old enough to
say i would grab a beer with you and we
could sit there and talk so yeah
sometimes we can sit down and grab a
beer i would love it but um
you just did the same thing and that's
my point with this we just don't think
there's any intellectual consistency to
it whatsoever you can't say well the
term trans woman because it's gender
it's different from sex and then say
they're allowed to compete with
biological females and then you just and
you've done this several times you just
said who identify
who identify as female or identify as
male yeah and that's my point is it's an
untenable position
and i don't think it's about protecting
trans women to use your term now see
what i did there uh i think ultimately
you need to look at the consequences
that harm biological women and they
deserve those same opportunities my
final point
i'm not you know sorry i'm not i'm not
gonna sit here and and claim that the
language is not confusing or that all
this stuff is not very new and like
uncharted territory
i am not the most educated person in
this
just because i do not understand
something for it does not mean i should
dismiss the validity of it you know
because obviously there are a group of
people who
like this is very important to them and
just because you know an even larger
group of people who it's important and
that's biological sure no i'm talking
about the trans issue specifically like
like
but why not take into account biological
females that's my point you don't seem
to be
i'm not even addressing the sports thing
i'm addressing what you were talking
about with the language issue okay which
is that um
i am you know still learning a lot of
stuff about this i am not the most
educated person on it the language is
confusing it's hard to integrate but at
the end of the day the complaints that
people are living are valid and it's
something that i think people should
approach with an open mind and just try
their best to understand
rather than shut it down immediately i
think that's kind of where i stand on it
just because it is something that is new
to you and maybe seems nonsensical does
not inherently disqualified from being
it's not new to me it's something i've
studied pretty extensively and i do
believe it's nonsense okay yeah and i
believe and i would certainly say
if not the term nonsensical it is
absolutely untenable okay it's an
untenable position to say that sex is
biological gender
is societal
and biological male should be allowed to
compete against biological females it's
an untenable position but i appreciate
you sitting down isaac isaac isaac thank
you much isaac well look at that i don't
find the arguments particularly
compelling
but respect genuinely to isaac for
sitting down with me and making his case
like an adult which reminds me i wanted
to ask you
have you had this discussion with people
in real life and
which arguments have you heard that were
the most compelling as it relates to
biological males competing in women's
sports just comment below and if you
like what you see hit the subscription
button or consider tuning in monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern for the
full daily show live that's 10 a.m
eastern live and i mean yes live that's
actually live uncensored
back to the topic at hand other times
with these discussions
you have to realize that some people
have no interest
in conversing
on these topics openly and honestly like
this guy
i mean what's the point of sports
to win
the population is born with intersex
traits that's from amnesty.org i mean
yeah i mean i can just like keep keep
like can you hold that up to the camera
can you hold that up to the camera
let me actually uh
is there a woman who would like to speak
to him
and that miracle my friends
is coming tomorrow so if you want to see
more smash the like button comment below
bookmark the channel come back tomorrow
at 10 a.m eastern just like every other
day
hey everybody if you liked the clip you
just saw go ahead and smash that like
button smash it also feel free to go
ahead and share it why not share it
people you like or you don't like landau
smash landau smash crowder smash black
widow
takes a smashing